hey everybody it's alec baldwin here i
was on the cover
of gq in february of 1990
and boy have things changed since then
i'm here with you now
to answer some questions from the
internet
[Music]
if donald trump invited alec baldwin to
lunch would he accept
you know if it was 20 years ago and i
was in my 40s
i might have you know before he was
president i ran into trump once because
we rented
a penthouse i shot a film that i
produced my company produced
a really beautiful film with ben
kingsley called the confession
our location department negotiated to
shoot on the top
of the trump building on the columbus
circle and apparently the entire top
floor
was divided into two huge units and one
of them was his or at least he kept it
in his pocket to sell
it was an empty floor-to-ceiling windows
and you're looking out at the city
beautiful looking east at the park and
everything
and he came by we were shooting one
night and he showed up he's like
everything good
you good did i take care of you did i
take care of you
everybody's good yes okay okay
and he leaves he like literally comes in
drive-bys and
he's in the same clothes he's at the
same long overcoat
and he said the same line he always says
he's like you want me to come in and sit
down do a quick shot of me
quick cameo all the movies that i'm in
do great they all do great
home alone every movie that i'm in is a
hit and we're all like
no i would not have lunch with him now
oh god no life's too short
does alec baldwin get death threats from
trump supporters for his parody of him
no i don't but of course i get a lot of
people
very vehement and very very passionate
about you know you should be ashamed of
what a disgrace
you are and you have no talent and your
career is over
and you're so irrelevant i always find
it funny that when people who have
twitter followings in the hundreds of
people they want me to make sure i know
how irrelevant i am
i get a lot of people criticizing me for
attacking
trump that never really bothers me what
role is alec baldwin best known for
you know playing trump on snl has
provided me with an audience
we did the show the other day and they
had huge numbers it was like the third
highest rated show since we've done the
trump thing
this show we did last the season
premiere with chris rock
and i'm going to say that obviously the
reason the numbers were so large is
because of chris rock and it was really
a pleasure to get to see him during this
miserable covert thing you know the
trump thing has been this weird
journey so i did all the episodes
produced season one
2016-17 a little bit less season two a
little bit less season three
and now we're back to do a handful of
these things between now and the
election and hopefully the election
things will change
and i'll never have to do this again but
other than that i would say
glengarry glen ross beetlejuice
hunt for red october you know things
that were successful projects
not through anything i did essentially
but i was along for the ride if you will
a 30 rock is the thing that people would
say the most things to me about i would
really get a lot of good
good feedback from people about that as
i've said countless times that was the
best job i've ever had and
probably ever will have because of how
smart tina is
and robert carlock and all the writers i
don't think anything can ever compare to
the writing that we had on 30 rock
twitter
[Music]
at alec baldwin i'm binging 30 rock it's
brilliant
it was only 10 years ago but i don't
think you could do that humor today
without the political correct police
going after you
do you agree i don't know the answer to
that question because i mean there's so
much content out there that
does just by happenstance maybe evade
the
political police there's so much stuff
out there that you see and go oh
these people here got nailed and these
people didn't get nailed i don't think
that the
political correctness police can do
their whack-a-mole thing
fast enough to catch everybody so those
that get nailed and those that don't get
nailed
it tends to be rather sporadic do i
think that 30 rocks said things that
would be
viewed differently now probably
imdb
trademark deep raspy voice sometimes
plays deeply narcissistic though
inherently moral characters
deadpan comic delivery thick dark hair
dimpled chin
god i think this is all wrong i think i
have a very sweet
kind of tenor voice i sometimes play
uh hypersensitive very wounded
characters
very needy characters i have no comic
delivery whatsoever
i once had thick dark hair fabulous hair
i had what i considered some of the best
hair in the business
now my hair is a steel gray like a kind
of a gun
metal gray my my hair looks like like a
dirty floor
maybe and uh my dimpled chin i think
sometimes i do i think i've had
a dimpled chin and then um i don't
you know in the real world i guess one
thing that covent has done is had me
like six months of just not eating what
i normally eat so
maybe my dimple's back reportedly
baldwin originally wanted to be a lawyer
before he was bit by the acting bug
well i went to school in washington i
went to george washington university for
three years
and i was in what people then used to
call kind of informally a pre-law
program where people were taking courses
that were
geared toward an understanding of how
laws are made and
i took about the american presidency and
american government and
foreign policy and so forth i really yes
i wanted to be a lawyer and there's
times
i still sit there and say boy did i make
a mistake
i should have gone to law school i feel
that way you know
probably once a month wikipedia
in new york city baldwin worked as a
busboy at the disco studio 54.
well when i arrived there in the fall of
1979
i got a job at studio 54 i walked in and
i got a job as a waiter now they had
busboys
who wore the little short shorts and
they were topless they were all
you know really super buffed out guys
and they were the busboys and the
waiters were people who went up usually
up into the balcony to ask people if
they wanted to order a drink from the
bar and there weren't many of us we wore
black shirts and black
pants and we looked like what shrager
and rubell would have you wear you know
you wear all black and i had a beard
a very dark beard it was a nutty part of
my life